the rich dad poor dad author says the
biggest crash in history
is coming he recommends buying bitcoin
and gold
and silver this is a story from benzinga
benzinga
um robert kiyosaki cautioned his
followers to prepare for the biggest
crash in world history by the way how
many times have we heard that the
biggest crash is coming the biggest
crash is coming it happens and then you
know we we recover so kiyosaki's been
warning on twitter
that the next crash would be a long one
and investors should buy more gold
silver and bitcoin when they can this is
based on his tweets starting in december
of 2020 when bitcoin was trading at 19
kiyosaki announced glad i bought bitcoin
next stop 50k by the way this was when
it was at 19 000.
four months later kiyosaki was right
bitcoin hit an all-time high of 65 000
but now what's happened since then
is bitcoin has since lost 40 percent of
its value and bitcoin is currently
dancing around
40 000 so
some people might say
look hold up kimo sabe
kiyosaki you want me to avoid a bubble
by investing in what's potentially
another bubble bitcoin because people
speculate that bitcoin's a bubble we'll
see your opinion on that so
look i i actually interviewed robert
kiyosaki
and i learned a lot if there was one
thing that i learned from him is he
loves silver yes loves silver obviously
gold he's recommending gold and he's
obviously recommending bitcoin i do have
some bitcoin i don't have silver yet but
that's something i'm looking into
um robert kiyosaki would hurt you right
now yeah he's actually so here's my
point we we got into it he we had some
different philosophical beliefs he's
actually the one person i've ever
interviewed who would not say
save that money he basically was like do
not save your money take on debt
buy use it to buy real estate
you know buy these assets
um these non-duplicatable assets gold
silver hard assets store value bitcoin
he's do not save your money that's not
that catchy though yeah well you know
he's controversial you have a rap song
look a lot of yeah
i do respect robert kiyosaki but here's
my
my point with robert kiyosaki
here's my two my two cents my two cents
remember one thing about robert kiyosaki
first and foremost he's a rich dad yeah
he's a rich dad so he's giving rich dad
advice
so he's worth a hundred million dollars
oh okay allegedly
allegedly all right so
he's he's made his money
i'm sorry what do you mean allegedly
this i don't know i just said he just
threw that
but here's what i would say yeah there's
levels to this game you know how they
say you gotta crawl before you walk you
gotta walk before you run you gotta run
before you you run a marathon i added
that last part
he's running marathons right now
so there's people who are basically just
starting to crawl just starting to walk
that have no money
that have no savings that have debt and
if they actually take robert kiyosaki at
his word
they're going to spend all their money
or maybe take on debt or buy silver buy
gold and they have no cash right they
have no cash
um
there's levels to this game if you're at
level one don't try to get to level five
if you're level one get to level two get
to level three get to level four then
you can get to level five kiyosaki's a
level five like david if i told you
don't worry about saving any money
just take on more debt buy some more
bitcoin you know talk to you in a year
or two
you'd be struggling to pay your bills
you'd be struggling to pay your rent
yeah sure i mean i don't know what's
wrong but i get what you mean yeah it
definitely would not be conducive to my
long-term goals so like not everybody's
advice is applicable to everyone so i
say save before you invest a lot of
people say well so what do you mean save
that money what do you mean save that
money saving
you know you barely beat inflation you
gotta invest that money stagnant okay so
i'm like i'm with you if you actually
look at my net worth 90 of my net worth
is in investments
but the only way that i was actually
able to get to invest was because i
saved that money save
that money so my advice to you is save
up
don't take on debt like
don't take on especially consumer debt
credit cards car debt
um
consumer loans uh shopping cards you
know uh the worst are the payday loans
right the um
those are the absolute worst you know
the seas of debt
consumer loans college loans car loans
credit cards
cash advances those are payday loans
those are the worst he's basically
saying take on debt to take to invest in
real estate
if you love real estate and you think
that's for you hell yeah you should do
it but not everybody's a real estate guy
so there's levels to this guy to this to
this game save before
you invest and that's why
robert kiyosaki would not say save that
money but for you at home save that
money so then you can start investing
that's our story
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken